there is a comedian michael rappaport
very emotional very left-wing comedian
very outspoken democrat comedian
he just took a video
he was in a drug store in new york and
he sees a guy some criminal walk in
fill up a bag full of stuff in a
drugstore
and just walk right out without paying
yo
i'm looking at this [ __ ] this dude
this [ __ ] yo that
this dude
i can't believe
i'm seeing this [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
yo
this [ __ ] guy just filled his two bags
up
with everything
in rite aid right here on
80th and 1st avenue is walking down the
street like [ __ ] is gucci look at me in
my face like what's
good he's i was watching him the whole
time
my man just went christmas shopping in
january
he had the condoms
the shampoo
but that's not possible michael
rappaport because aoc told me this isn't
really happening there's been a spate of
drugstore robberies going on coast to
coast sea to shining sea
cvs walgreens duane reed all these
places are closing stores and they're
closing stores because
people are robbing them blind there are
other reasons as well but that's a big
part of it
talking millions and millions of dollars
worth of stuff and the left led by aoc
says one this isn't happening and if you
say it's happening you're a racist why i
don't know you are
and two
the reason it is happening is because
people need to feed their families
they always this is like when dr fauci
said there there is no gain of function
research we're not funding gain of
function and all the gain of function
with funding is fine
which is it you're speaking out of both
sides of your mouth you're contradicting
yourself that's what aoc is doing here
there is no
robbery epidemic in drug stores and also
it's great that they're stealing stuff
they need to feed their families well
michael rappaport says here uh he ain't
stealing a loaf of bread
this guy was stealing boxes of condoms
okay you don't need that to feed you you
need that to stop from having a family
you need that to prevent your family
from growing
if you're not going to remain abstinent
but you certainly don't need
you don't need that to feed your family
so this guy goes in steals a bunch of
stuff he's probably going to go sell it
on the street
and take the money
daily wire reported that
cvs just cvs alone has announced it will
close about 900 retail locations over
the next three years that's about nine
percent of its ten thousand stores
this is at least partially attributed to
the increased theft
and michael rappaport he's so confused
the democrats they're so confused
why
how is this happening
in new york city
criminals are being allowed to go into
shops and commit crimes and then just
walk away and not be arrested or
prosecuted
oh we need to get some investigators how
did this happen
could it could it have something to do
with the fact that democrat prosecutors
and politicians decriminalized all of
this stuff
could it look i don't know i'm no
forensic investigator but it would seem
to me that when you have a bunch of
prosecutors and politicians go in and
say we're not going to prosecute these
crimes
and if you were arrested for these
crimes we're going to let you go
that hm maybe you're going to get more
of those crimes
i don't know what do i know i'm no
expert i don't have a degree in this
stuff
michael rappaport voted for this stuff
new york voted for this stuff
it's very sad i love new york
it's it's my home state spent a lot of
time there since i was a kid
and there is there actually is a kind of
base level conservatism to new yorkers a
lot of people outside of new york don't
understand this it's the kind of trumpy
conservatism
the idea that i'm not going to take any
bs from anybody the idea that i'm going
to get in your face a little bit
the idea that i you know it's the
the political scene in new york it's not
like berkeley california it's not not
like san francisco it's not hippie dippy
stuff but they still vote
for democrats and then they have to deal
with the results of these policies
you don't need some big thick
thesis on political philosophy to
understand let the criminals out going
to get more crime okay
and i think there are a lot of people
who are i don't know about michael
rapaport he's still probably a big dem
but
there are a lot of people who are in the
middle who are independents who are soft
liberals who are going to look at this
and say you know
i don't think so no more they are they
tried to do this in this mayoral
election the guy who ran as a democrat
eric adams but he ran on a very pro cop
kind of message
and so he was he was positioning himself
as the moderate democrat he's not
governing as a moderate democrats it's
probably not going to work
but
that that i think that was part of the
phenomenon and you saw it obviously in
the 90s with giuliani even a very very
left-wing city like new york elects this
republican who's specifically tough on
crime
most successful mayor in the history of
new york this is not complicated for
republicans
crime
education
and immigration depending on which area
of the country you're running in very
simple run on those three things you're
going to do pretty well oh hello my lady
or my lord it is i your friend the lord
michael knowles how did i become a lord
i did not need to be knighted by queen
elizabeth i just had to be close to
established
titles your opportunity to earn the
title of lord or lady in scotland all
you need is a one square foot plot of
land and a certificate established
titles is a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards or lords and ladies
in english in your title pack you will
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land these title
packs are a fantastic gift and you could
even get a couple pack for you and your
partner where you can get adjoining
plots of land with this certificate you
could officially change your name to
lord or lady get it put on your credit
card plane tickets etc even put it on
your dating profiles they're having a
great valentine's day sale so go to
establishedtitles.com
save 10 off today remember to use
discount code knowles or click the link
below that's establishedtitles.com
knowles or just click the link below my
lords and my ladies
hold up stop don't put down the mouse do
people still use
mouse probably not
don't go anywhere ring that bell
subscribe
you will get the notifications for this
show if you don't get the notifications
then you should definitely head over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]